so last weekend you watch that cable
show set in the sort of fantasy world
looks faintly like reality has the great
costumes really tense conflict I was
actually thinking in mad men but maybe
you were think of Game of Thrones and
that's sort of the point I want to make
today we're in the middle of one of
those genre kerfuffles that happens once
in a while where literary folks start
talking about genre you know it's
shorthand for science fiction or
mysteries or horror romance and
sometimes they're on the attack and
sometimes they're being sort of
apologetic you know they talk about a
guilty pleasure and then the genre folks
respond and either defend or go on the
attack themselves actually this time
around Lev Grossman wrote a really nice
piece in time talking about the
pleasures and similarities between what
we call genre and literature ursula
leguin wrote a nice piece few years ago
about the same thing the point that i
want to make and the reason i brought up
mad man at the top is that it's kind of
all genre now what we're really talking
about her coming up with a fictional
world and a central character a
protagonist who by denton being a
protagonist is somehow special trying to
navigate a world that is even if it's
based on real life imaginary it's a
magical world you know whether you're
watching the Black Widow fight aliens or
Jane Eyre fight the strictures and mores
of society you're still watching a story
what you don't want is boring right we
already have boring you know what real
life is like you want an imaginary life
I may not be the best person to talk
about this a couple years ago I was
having drinks with the head of the
sci-fi network and I was asking whether
I was too much of a fan sometimes I was
talking about the show the Gilmore Girls
my wife really enjoys enjoyed and asked
him you know you think maybe I would
really like the gilmore girls if it was
set in space and the publicist for the
network was next to him and she leaned
in and said you're meeting with the head
of the sci-fi network and the best you
can pitch is gilmore girls in space no
no it wasn't a pitch but you know it was
a it was a good point i think that was
the best i could pitch and the other
night we were watching mad men and i
looked over at my wife and i said you
think i would like to show better if it
was set on another planet and she knows
me really well she leaned in padded
on the hand and said sweetie it is